يظن الناس أنك سمعت جو بايدن الذي يبلغ من العمر
80 عامًا قبل أن يصبح عيد الشكر
مع اختباره الإيجابي
للطمع الأخير في سلسلة طويلة من الرؤساء
الذين عانوا من مرض خطير أثناء وجودهم
في المنصب
، قلل مساعدو دونالد ترامب من
خطورة نوبته مع كوفيد إن  في
خريف عام 2020 ، والذي هبط به في
مركز والتر ريد الطبي ، لكن لاحقًا كشف كتاب كتبه
رئيس أركان ترامب السابق مارك
ميدوز أن ترامب كان ضعيفًا للغاية
في الوقت الذي لم يستطع فيه حمل حقيبة
إلى المروحية التي نقلته
إلى المستشفى وذلك
انخفضت مستويات الأكسجين لديه إلى
مستوى منخفض بشكل خطير بعد ساعات فقط من إعلانه عن
إصابته بالفيروس عندما أظهر الرئيس السابق
انخفاضًا في مستوى الأكسجين في دمه مما
يشير بقوة إلى أنه مصاب بالتهاب
رئوي وهذه إحدى الطرق التي تموت
منها.
حتى إذا وضعنا جانباً محللي الوباء ،
يقولون إن الضغط الهائل للوظيفة يجعل
الرئيس عرضة للإصابة بالمرض ، فإن
الرئاسة تسرع من أي
نقاط ضعف.  يعاني جسم الإنسان من
بعض المخاوف الصحية الرئاسية التي
كان يكتنفها الغموض أو تم
التستر عليها قرب نهاية عام 1919 ،
أصيب الرئيس وودرو ويلسون
بجلطة دماغية شديدة أخرجته من
الخدمة دون علم الجمهور
ولم يتم إخبار الأمريكيين بمدى
مرضه  لم يتم إخبارهم بمدى
تدمير السكتة الدماغية ،
ونتيجة لذلك لم يتم إخبارهم أنه لمدة
17 شهرًا تقريبًا كانت
الرئيسة العاملة الفعلية للولايات المتحدة هي
السيدة الأولى إديث ويلسون خلال فترة
رئاسته.
كان يعاني من آلام خطيرة في
الظهر ومشاكل معوية ،
والتي كان معظمها مخفيًا عن المؤرخين العامين ،
ما زالوا يناقشون ما إذا كان رونالد
ريغان ، الذي تم تشخيص إصابته لاحقًا بمرض
الزهايمر ، قد أظهر علامات المرض
بينما كان لا يزال في منصبه ،
نفى مساعدوه أن بعض أمراض الرئيس
يمكن أن تغير المسار  من تاريخ
جلطة ويلسون ، يقول تيم نفتالي إنه أحدث
اختلافًا حاسمًا  CE في نهاية الحرب العالمية
الأولى ،
جعلت جلسته الشديدة من
المستحيل عليه الحصول على دعم الكونغرس
لمعاهدة فرساي التي تعني
أن الولايات المتحدة لم تصدق أبدًا
على المعاهدة مما يعني أن الولايات المتحدة
لم تشارك في عصبة
الأمم ولا تزال  ناقشنا ما إذا كان
ضعف صحة Fdr قد أضر بقدرته
على التفاوض مع جوزيف ستالين في يالطا
في عام 1945.
لماذا كان هناك نزعة لمساعدة
وأقارب بعض الرؤساء
لحماية أمراضهم من الجمهور
هناك هذا
المفهوم أنه بطريقة ما إذا كان الرئيس
لديه أي شيء  نوع من المشكلة الطبية ، إنه
عيب أو نقطة ضعف ، أود أن أزعم
أن التعتيم
يصبح خطرًا ، سألت الدكتور جوناثان
راينر ما هي أفضل طريقة للحفاظ على
لياقة الرئيس أثناء وجوده في المنصب ، قال
بغض النظر عن مدى انشغال
جدول الرئيس المزدحم من الصباح
حتى  في الليل ، يتعين عليهم تخصيص وقت
لأنفسهم لممارسة الرياضة حتى لو كانت
45 دقيقة فقط ويقول إنه يأخذ
عطلات نهاية الأسبوع  ay في منتجع رئاسي
سيساعد
صحتهم الجسدية والعقلية براين تود سي إن إن واشنطن